good afternoon and welcome again to the
commissioners press room today 18th of
July 2018 it's our pleasure to have with
us
Commissioner Marcus Mosiah who will
present make a statement on an antitrust
decision and a commission make the
statement then we'll move on to our
traditional Q&A session without further
ado commissioner well thank you today
the Commission has decided to find
Google four point three four billion
euros for breaching EU antitrust rules
Google has engaged in illegal practices
to cement its dominant market position
in Internet's search it must put an
effective end to this contact within 90
days or face penalty payments Google's
search engine is its track ship product
do you fine
every year Google generates more than 95
billion u.s. dollars from AdWords such
as own shown and clicked on by users of
Google search and much of this revenue
is thanks to the rise of smart mobile
devices namely smartphones and tablets
today mobile internet makes more than
half of global Internet traffic it has
changed the lives for millions of
Europeans no matter if we're waiting for
the metro or the boss if we are in a
meeting room if we're dining with
friends more and more our hands reach
for our smartphones and tablets to find
the information that we're looking for
our case is about three types of
restrictions that Google has imposed on
mobile device manufacturers and network
operators to ensure that traffic goes to
Google search first Google has required
manufacturers to pre install the Google
search and browser apps on devising on
devices running on the Android mobile
operating system manufacturers have to
do this if they wanted to be able to
sell devices with the Google App Store
second Google paid manufacturers and
network operators to make sure that only
the Google Search app was pre-installed
on such devices third Google has
obstructed the development of competing
mobile operating systems these could
have provided a platform for rival
search engines to gain traffic in this
way Google has used Android as a vehicle
to cement its dominance in as a search
engine
these practices they have denied ribose
a chance to innovate and to compete on
the merits they have denied European
consumers the benefit
of effective competition in the very
important mobile sphere and this is
illegal under EU antitrust rules I would
like now to tell you a bit more about
four aspects of our case first why
Google has implemented these practices
seconds what practices Google implements
it's exactly third why these practices
are illegal under EU and cisserus rules
and finally how our decision today will
affect Google consumers and the
marketplace so first what was Google's
strategy Google understood early on the
shift from desktop to mobile search it
started in the mid-2000s and it would be
a fundamental change for search Indian
businesses and of course it realized
that this was both an opportunity and a
risk so Google developed the strategy to
anticipate the changes of the shift this
strategy was built on the mobile
operating system Android as Google said
in one of its internal documents at the
time and I quote Android is by far the
greatest opportunity for search
monetization in mobile over the next
year's and is very strategic to Google
encrypt Google bought the original
developer of the Android operating
system in 2005 and it has continued to
develop Android ever since it has been
very successful today around 80% of
smart devices in Europe and worldwide
run on Android this is more than 2.2
billion devices in total each time
Google releases a new version of Android
it publishes the source code online this
in principle allows anyone to access
and modify the code to create other
versions of Android so called Android
forks at the same time this openly
accessible Android source code only
covers basic functions on mobile devices
it does not include popular google apps
like the Google Play Store which enables
users to download more than 3.3 million
different apps if manufacturers want to
sell android devices that have popular
google apps they need to agree to
Google's terms and to sign on the dotted
line and this includes requirements not
to motive modify the Android source code
without Google's consent through this
requirement in practice Android is
locked down in a Google controlled
ecosystem so what are the illegal
practices that Google put in place our
case is about three specific types of
restrictions three specific restrictions
that Google has imposed on manufacturers
and mobile network operators the first
practice ensure that Android device
device manufacturers pre-installed the
Google Search app and the Google Chrome
browser on the devices that they sell
search and browser app are the most
important gateways to reach search
engines on mobile devices manufacturers
had to pre install the Google search and
the chrome app if they wanted to sell
devices that offers users a key feature
namely the possibility to download other
apps via the Google Play Store as part
of our investigation device
manufacturers confirmed that GU that
users consider Google's Play Store a
must-have
on Android devices so the rights to pre
install the Play Store on their device
is a very strong incentive for them to
agree to Google's demands especially
because it's not possible for users to
download the Play Store themselves
second Google also wanted Google search
to be the only pre-installed search
engine on Android devices so Google gave
some of the largest device manufacturers
a share of the pie of Google search
revenue in two but only on a condition
of exclusive status it also entered into
such arrangement with certain mobile
network operators which can also
determine which apps are installed on
the devices that they sell to consumers
at its peak this practice covered more
than 80 percent of Android devices sold
in Europe Google stopped his practice
after the Commission started to look
into it our investigation has shown that
for search apps and mobile browsers
pre-installation on devices is an
advantage that cannot be matched in any
way the figures they speak for
themselves in 2016 more than 95 percent
of all search queries on Android devices
were made via Google search these
devices at Google search and Google
Chrome pre-installed on windows mobile
systems or their devices on the other
hand well the Google search engine was
not pre-installed as a result less than
25% of all search queries was made via
Google search and more than 75 percent
of the queries well they happened on
Bing which is the pre-installed search
engine on windows mobile devices
there is a saying that you that you
don't look a gift horse in the mouth
well evidence shows that when it comes
to search apps and mobile browsers the
vast majority of users simply take what
comes with their device and do not
download competing apps in fact these
apps are not even for free since users
pay with their data or to slightly
paraphrase but also economists Milton
Friedman has said there ain't no such
thing as a free search the third
practice Google has put in place as
already mentioned prevents device
manufacturers from using any alternative
version of Android that was not approved
by Google if manufacturers produced even
a single device based on an android fork
they used the right they lose the right
to sell any device with Google Play
Store or the Google Search app and this
is how Google restricts the opportunity
and incentive for others to develop
Android Forks in a way that is not open
to all at the same time this reduced the
opportunity for rival search engines and
other to launch apps and services on
devices running on Android Forks this
was not just a remote possibility from
theory books in 2012 and 2013
Amazon tried to license to device
manufacturers its Android 4 called fire
OS it wanted to cooperate with
manufacturers to increase its chances of
commercial success and manufacturers
were interested but due to Google's
restrictions manufacturers could not
launch fire OS
and even a single device they would have
lost the right to sell any Android phone
with key google apps nowadays very few
devices run with fire OS namely only
those manufactured by Amazon themselves
and this is not a proportionate outcome
Google is entitled to set technical
requirements to ensure that
functionality and apps within its own
Android ecosystem runs smoothly but
these technical requirements cannot
serve as a smokescreen to prevent the
development of competing androids
ecosystems Google cannot have its cake
and eat it so why are these practices
illegal under EU rules in Europe well of
course we congratulate all companies for
success the excess success that they
achieve through innovation developing
products that consumers value and that
is why as such dominance is not a
problem under EU antitrust rules but
with market dominance comes a
responsibility and that's because when
one company dominates the marketplace
obviously competition is weakened so new
antitrust rules puts a special
responsibility on dominant companies
they must not deny other companies the
chance to compete against them on the
merits of course because that would be
to the detriment of further innovation
and therefore harm European consumers
through its control over Android Google
is dominant in the market for mobile
operating systems which are available to
licensed to other manufacturers google
has been dominant in this market since
2000 and
our most recent figures show that it
holds a market share of more than 95%
the second biggest player in this
markets
Windows Mobile was very small in
comparison you'd have a market share of
less than 5% before exiting the market
last year other mobile operating systems
like those of Apple and Blackberry they
are not available for license they do
not directly compete with Android at the
level of device manufacturers of course
Android phones they compete with Apple
and Blackberry phones for in consumers
but our investigation showed that that
does not sufficiently constraint
Google's power and visa vie device
manufacturers and network operators our
decision also concludes that Google is
dominant in two other markets namely the
App Store for the Android mobile
operating system and in general internet
search
as regards app stores Google Play Store
accounts for more than 90% of app
downloads on Android devices as regards
general internet search the Google
search engine hold very high market
shares of over 90% in most European
countries and that we all ready showed
in the Google Shopping decision last
year this means that Google must comply
with EU antitrust rules for dominant
companies and the decision today
concludes that the restrictions Google
imposed on manufacturers and network
operators using Android have breached
these rules since 2011 first that's
because Google's practices have denied
rival search engines the possibility to
compete on the merits they made sure
that Google search engine is
pre-installed on practically all Android
devices we
and advances that cannot be matched and
by making payments to major
manufacturers and network operators on
condition that no other search app or
search engine was pre-installed
well then rivals were excluded from this
opportunity in this way Google also
denied rivals access to valuable data
from increased user traffic which in
turn could have allowed rivals to
improve their products furthermore
Google's practices also harmed
competition and further innovation in
the wider mobile space beyond just
internet search and that's because they
prevented other mobile browsers from
competing effectively with the
pre-installed google chrome browser
finally they obstructed the development
of Android Forks this could have
provided a platform for rival search
engines as well as other app developers
to thrive so finally the consequences of
this decision the fine of four point
three four billion euros reflects the
seriousness and the sustained nature of
Google's violation of EU antitrust rules
the decision requires Google to bring
its illegal conduct to an end within 90
days in an effective manner
at a minimum our our decision requires
Google to stop and not to re-engage in
the three types of restrictions that I
have described in other words our
decision stops Google from controlling
which search and browser apps
manufacturers can pre install on Android
Android devices or which Android
operating system they can adopt but it
is Google's sole responsibility to make
sure that it changes his conduct
in a way that brings the infringement to
an effective end we will monitor this
very closely if Google fails to come to
comply with our decision it would be
subject to penalty payments the penalty
would be up to five percent of the
average daily turnover of alphabet
Google's parent for each day of
non-compliance we would have to
establish this in a separate commission
decision which the penalty would be back
dated when the non-compliance started so
our decision requires Google to change
the way it operates and face the
consequences of its action about a year
ago I was here in the press room to tell
you about a separate another separate
decision concerning Google the
Commission find Google two point four
two billion euros for abusing its
dominant as a search engine by giving an
illegal advantage to own shopping
comparison service we have not yet taken
a position on whether Google has
complied with the decision and since we
haven't done so this remains very much
an open question
furthermore the Commission also
continues to investigate Google's
business practices concerning other
vertical search services and Adsense
I cannot preclude prejudge the outcome
of these ongoing investigations which
continue to be a top priority for us so
to conclude what our ongoing work and
today's decision have in common is the
principle that in Europe companies must
compete on the merits any company is
welcome to do business in our single
market but they need to comply they need
to play by EU antitrust rules
and these rules are set in place for a
very simple reason to protect European
consumers and effective competition and
this matters especially in digital
markets technology companies have
enormous potential of doing us good but
establishing people's trust that
technology serves us and not the other
way around is more important than ever
competition enforcement can make a
difference here it can give people the
confidence that technology companies
play fair
and do not close off markets to
competition otherwise they will be
sanctioned as Google was today but we
also need effective regulation including
data protection rules that ensure our
data is not being misused and rules that
make sure that Ahtna online platforms
operate in a transparent way and that is
why I work hand-in-hand with my
colleagues Andrus Ansip Maria Gabriella
and Vera euroval to build the Trust's we
need to make sure that digital markets
truly serve European consumers thank you